sag doch mal du bist ja schon sehr sehr
nah dran jetzt geschehen eigentlich ja
ich würde das eher sagen nicht so gut
denn wenn es ihm wirklich gut ginge oder
es würde signifikante schritte nach
vorne geben dann würden wir etwas höre
dann gebe es ja keinen grund das nicht
zu vermelden
das heißt für mich es gibt zu den
damaligen auskünften nichts neues leider
leider keine entwicklung so dass da
einfach nur hoffen bleibt denn sonst
hätten wir was gehört gesehen gemerkt
das ist sicherlich ein realistisch aber
auch traurige standort für die schöne
natürlich das mit schumacher in seine
fußstapfen tritt
was für eine zukunft siehst du für ihn
in der formel 1 also definitiv wird da
reinkommen das ist klar und dann ist die
frage wie behauptet er sich daran
[Musik]
es ist kein geheimnis dass er nicht weg
sagt sein vater entspricht es ist kommt
jetzt kein neuer senna kein neuer max
verstappen aber es kommt ein sehr guter
fahrer der der gute lernkurve hat das
heißt er gehört hat ein der wird auch
stattfinden aber er braucht definitiv
länger als sein vater wenn man den
unfairen vergleich heranziehen da aber
dennoch geht's immer vorwärts und
deswegen wird er auch sein weg gehen das
sehen wir jetzt in der formel 2 auf
[Musik]